début des années 2000 un nouveau mode de
consommation locale et solidaire
émergent en france une quarantaine de
consommateurs de la région d'aubagne
regroupés au sein de l'association pour
le maintien d'une agriculture paysanne
ont décidé de se passer de la grande
distribution
voici la première amap française une
association pour le maintien de
l'agriculture paysanne créée en 2001
dans le var le principe
les adhérents de l'association paye à
l'avance la récolte de l'agriculteur en
échange ils reçoivent chaque semaine un
panier de légumes frais et bio pour les
producteurs ce nouveau système de vente
est une garantie de ressources
le maraîcher daniel vuillon été à
l'initiative du projet là on va la
trésorerie puisqu'au mois de chiffre
d'affaires
à voir avant d'avoir commencé à produire
ça change tout dans les données du
problème et puis surtout on est beaucoup
plus serein parce que dans l'hiver que
le chou souvent ne se vendent pas pour
moi c'est plus mon souci
mon souci c'est de faire nos plus beaux
shows qui soit pour satisfaire mes
clientes dans déjà acheté un moyen
d'éviter les intermédiaires et
d'échapper à la pression des grandes
surfaces une réalité défendu à l'époque
par les mouvements altermondialistes
ainsi que par des groupes de
consommateurs mobilisés contre la
malbouffe et l'insécurité alimentaire
c'est un engagement responsable on est
des consommateurs les consom'acteurs le
concept résonne dans toute la france
très vite des amap fleurissent sur tout
le territoire regroupés parfois en
réseau régional
certaines villes participent même à ces
initiatives exemple à nantes
en 2010 la ville mettait des locaux
scolaires à disposition des amap pour la
réception des paniers ce qu'on fait
aujourd'hui accepté d'ouvrir les écoles
aux amap c'est comme ça que la ville se
positionne une ville qui est dans une
position du facilitateur qui essaie de
créer les conditions pour que cette
démarche plus avancées aujourd'hui en
france environ 3000 amap sont répartis
sur tout le territoire et l'engouement
des consommateurs est toujours le même
on est sûr de la qualité des légumes des
fruits
c'est vrai que c'est du producteur au
consommateur donc c'est en banlieue en
poussant la des petites recettes pour
nous apprendre certains légumes connaît
une volonté de consommer à l'échelle
locale renforcée ces derniers mois avec
la crise due qu'aux victimes
[Musique]